[Música]
esta historia que les voy a contar
comenzó en la noche del pasado 3 de
febrero un tren de carga que viajaba
desde el estado de Pensilvania a illinoy
en Estados Unidos por razones aún no
conocidas descarriló y se incendió a
simple vista Parecía un lamentable
accidente pero pronto quedó en evidencia
la magnitud y el peligro que
representaba y para poder extinguir y
evitar una explosión de Gran tamaño fue
necesario hacer entonces agujeros en los
tanques de los diferentes vagones que
estaban descarrilados para extraer los
productos químicos que fueron entonces a
parar a diferentes fosas fosas
exclusivamente excavadas para poder
prenderles fuego de manera controlada y
extinguirlos durante varias horas las
llamas Pues consumieron los químicos y
el humo tóxico se hizo presente en la
localidad de East palantines
ante la toxicidad del ambiente las
autoridades impusieron una evacuación
obligatoria de los 5.000 habitantes las
autoridades indicaron que las
condiciones después de las quemas pues
ya eran seguras Pese a que los
habitantes presentaban algunos síntomas
como dolor de cabeza náuseas y debilidad
desde la Casa Blanca en Washington
afirmaron estar en comunicación con las
autoridades del estado de Ohio lugar
donde tuvo lugar este accidente ahora
sobre la mesa queda entonces la
posibilidad de que la empresa norfolks
soder que es la propiedad de este tren
descarrilado pague por la limpieza de
estos químicos y también enfrente
sanciones económicas pero lo que queda
sobre la mesa es el desastre ambiental
que esto está causando
10 días después del descarrilamiento de
un tren en Ohio que causó un grave
impacto ambiental los vecinos al de años
a las vías férreas dicen sentirse
enfermos por los químicos tóxicos en el
agua y el aire he tenido dolores de
cabeza dolor de garganta mi nariz gotea
y mis ojos lloran constantemente como
con ardor picazón los temores entre
estas poblaciones no son infundados
según expertos ya que el accidentado
tren operado por North Food sauden
Corporation transportaba al menos cinco
productos químicos tóxicos como cloruro
de vinilo asociados con diferentes tipos
de cáncer esto también lo demuestran los
peces muertos hallados en las vías
fluviales cercanas
el mayor problema con la respuesta en
este momento es el hecho de que las
agencias estatales y gubernamentales
locales no han sido transparentes con
los datos que tienen y cómo están
tomando decisiones sobre el envío de
personas de regreso al área y si el agua
en el área es o no segura
la agencia de protección medioambiental
estadounidense ordenó a la empresa pagar
la limpieza del accidente ferroviario y
el vertido químico una medida respaldada
por el presidente Joe biden que señaló
que responsabilizará a las empresas
ferroviarias que no antepongan la
seguridad
si la empresa no completa cualquier
acción ordenada por la Epa la agencia
intervendrá de inmediato realizaremos el
trabajo nosotros mismos y luego obligará
a North paulderm apagar el triple del
costo de acuerdo con los poderes
otorgados por mi agencia
por su parte el responsable del
accidente aseguró estar de centrado en
Reparar los daños medioambientales
generados con los vertidos así como
mejorar las medidas de seguridad para
evitar futuros desastres
quedan entonces varias preguntas sobre
la mesa del debate por qué esta
emergencia medioambiental parece no ser
prioridad para las autoridades federales
Qué tipo de derrame es del derrame que
estamos hablando qué repercusiones tiene
esto para el medio ambiente en esa zona
y Qué riesgos medioambientales estamos
expuestos o están expuestas las personas
que viven cerca del lugar de los hechos
por eso hoy en el debate de France 24
hablamos de medio ambiente y hablamos
del accidente de Ohio que pasa
desapercibido por los medios de
comunicación pero no en France 24 para
analizar el tema hemos invitado a Carlos
Ruiz docente de la facultad de química
de la Universidad Nacional de México
también está con nosotros Javier Acuña
especialista en protección radiológica y
gestión de energía es docente de
emergencias ambientales de la
universidad Argentina uade también es
jefe del departamento de protección
portuaria de el puerto de la ciudad de
Buenos Aires en Argentina ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pase parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f24 a
mí me encuentran en Twitter como arroba
Santi logo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos del programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Carlos y Carlos Gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en el programa Y pregunta
para El Punto de partida punto de inicio
de esta discusión y este análisis A qué
tipo de accidente
medioambiental en el que están
involucrados estos químicos nos estamos
enfrentando
nos vamos a enfrentando a un problema
que realmente sí es es grave pero ya
siento yo que ya ya solucionado la mayor
parte de ese problema sobre todo de que
no hubo una explosión en el momento del
descarrilamiento sino más bien lograron
hacer una
combustión controlada de los productos
que tenía es muy común que a través de
las vías de ferrocarril
transporten una gran cantidad de
productos químicos para eso existe toda
una normatividad
y evitar problemas que pueda haber y
también la gente que nos está
transportando tiene la capacitación para
saber qué hacer en el un caso de
emergencia de hecho existe una
normatividad en la cual se marca cada
uno de los diferentes químicos para
saber cómo tratar en caso de un
accidente uno de esos químicos ahora se
había Comparado con chernóbil este caso
desde mi punto de vista es totalmente
diferente es un problema de
contaminación química que va a ser de
corto plazo
no lo estoy minimizando pero no va a
tener efectos residuales a muy largo
plazo la opinión de Carlos nuestro
invitado vamos a preguntarle a Javier en
la ciudad de Buenos Aires a Qué tipo de
accidente con estos químicos nos estamos
enfrentando para conocer su opinión como
Punto de partida de este análisis Javier
bienvenido adelante
bueno muchas gracias buenas tardes sí
principalmente me parece importante
comprender la toma de decisiones que
hubo en la emergencia en una emergencia
es una situación caótica no normal y
muchas veces se toman decisiones
en base a la mejor de las peores en este
caso se menciona la quema controlada y
mencionabas y se mencionaba el tema de
los productos que se habían este
liberado Y más allá de la explosión que
es cierto digamos a un aumento de
temperatura un producto que tiene una
reacción se llama de polimerización o
sea puede reaccionar violentamente se
podía producir una explosión a muchos
kilómetros O sí kilómetros de distancia
que podían verse afectados Pero
principalmente este producto
el cloruro de vinilo lo que tenemos que
tener en cuenta es algo que se llama
densidad de vapor que es la densidad que
puede tener respecto al aire en este
caso uno es aire y esto tiene dos punto
dos Qué quiere decir que si el producto
al derramarse si hubiese dejado y no
quemado en los gases los vapores es lo
que les digo que es más pesado que el
aire hubiesen entrado a la localidad
fíjense que está muy cerca la vía de la
de la población si podría haber una un
gran incendio en el en todo lo que es la
población Y entonces esta decisión de
quemar tiene que ver también con poder
prevenir en sí la explosión de un
producto que es altamente reactivo y a
su vez también prevenir el ingreso del
contaminante a la ciudad que digamos
como no lo vimos y vimos inmensamente la
columna de humo que es realmente
impresionante pero puedo asegurar que en
ese caso fue una buena decisión producto
de las características del químico no
Bueno pues Punto de partida aclarado
sobre esta situación con nuestros dos
invitados continuó con Javier para hacer
la ronda en sentido contrario ya hay una
aparente investigación por parte de las
autoridades sobre lo que pudo haber
sucedido en algunas imágenes que
muestran algunas cámaras de seguridad se
ve a los dos últimos vagones de este
convoy de este tren
con un sobrecalentamiento de las ruedas
y puede ser uno de los factores que
llevó a este descarrilamiento es algo
que todavía está en investigación es
simplemente una de las hipótesis que hay
que pudo haber sucedido acá Aquí se
mezclan muchos factores Javier Pero
puede haber sido simplemente un
accidente mecánico problema con la carga
con el peso de la carga eran 150 vagones
cargados con diferentes químicos en
diferentes contenedores Cuáles son los
factores qué hipótesis pueden haber para
haber causado este accidente partiendo
de la idea que hay una investigación y
que y que eso luego dará alguna algunos
resultados
Bueno lo último es que tú dices es lo
más importante digamos hay una
investigación en curso el titular de la
junta de investigación de accidentes en
el transporte llamó justamente a ser
responsables como bien mencionabas
recién este en cuanto a la información
tampoco uno puede dejar de lado los
condicionamientos de seguridad
en Pos quizás de los este recursos
financieros y hubo una reducción de
personal se Comenta en los medios y
aumentó fíjense que ustedes ha aumentado
anualmente un tres por ciento la
producción y el transporte de estos
productos Habría que ver si aumentó de
la misma manera la la inversión en
seguridad no
fíjense que en el 2022 hubo 11
descarrilamientos lo que pasa que no
involucraron sustancias peligrosas de
hecho de los 120 vagones que mencionás
veinte tenían sustancias peligrosas y
cinco fueron los siniestrados con con
este
en particular quizás sea demasiado
pronto hablar los los accidentes
nosotros
una portuaria también somos Puerto
multimodal Tenemos también trenes y esto
ocurre digamos y bueno la gran
diferencia es que se vieron involucrados
estos productos químicos que a su vez el
tren claro no estaba catalogado como
peligroso justamente por la cantidad
Digamos si bien se derramaron casi dos
mil productos Perdón se derramaron hubo
una fuga de 200.000 litros en base a
esos cinco vagones aproximadamente
hay que tener en cuenta justamente las
acciones iniciales que se que se fueron
hechas tanto el tres de febrero que
comenzó el evento y la quema comienza
recién El Seis no O sea un tiempo para
decidir claro un tiempo prudencial
también para evaluar la la magnitud de
la situación Carlos regreso con usted
antes de empezar a hablar de los de los
diferentes compuestos químicos y
entender de que estamos hablando de Cuál
era la carga que estaba llevando este
tren muchas críticas sobre el modo de
transporte de este tipo de químicos
obviamente después de este accidente
pues vienen todas estas críticas en
torno a la seguridad de los trenes para
poder transportar este tipo de cargas
químicas si también la infraestructura
de Estados Unidos está lo
suficientemente actualizada y bien
mantenida para garantizar la seguridad y
evitar los descarrilamientos Javier
hablaba de unos 11 descarrilamientos a
lo largo del 2022 en diferentes partes
del mundo no solamente en Estados Unidos
pero qué tan seguro es transportar estos
químicos por vía férrea o hay otra forma
de poderlo hacer teniendo en cuenta que
esto atraviesa por muchas poblaciones y
centros urbanos
mi opinión es ya analizando bien las
situaciones es de que es uno de los
medios más seguros que hay el utilizar
el ferrocarril para transportar los
productos químicos Porque esos no de los
medios más seguros porque está por una
vía que es fija no está como una
carretera
se pueden transportar cantidades muy
grandes y de hecho a pesar de que es muy
aparatoso el accidente Habría que ver
los miles de millones de litros y de
kilos que se producen y se transportan
de un lugar a otro y realmente el número
de accidentes que hay es muy bajo Con
respecto a la cantidad de material que
se está
suministrando y lo que decía Javier creo
que tiene toda la razón el vinilo es más
denso que el aire si no se hubiera
tomado la decisión de quemarlo si
hubiera hecho una nube y hubiera entrado
a las casas y hubiera explotado en
México tuvimos experiencia en los años
setenta Tuvimos una fuga de gas de Pemex
y murió en más de dos mil personas por
eso y también tuvimos otra experiencia A
mediados de los setenta y de los setenta
en setenta y cinco donde una explosión
del Cloruro de vinilo y
se estaba descargando un vagón de chloé
vinilo o una chispa hubo una explosión O
sea no fue una
incineración controlada y salieron los
tanques a una distancia de más de dos
kilómetros si es una nube tóxica y
cerquita de ahí estaba una de las
plantas de la Volkswagen de mayor
producción de México se echaron a perder
dos mil coches en esa época Sí entonces
siento yo que a pesar de que son muy
aparatosos accidentes y nosotros
consideramos el número de toneladas que
se están manejando o de miles o millones
de toneladas que se manejan por vía
férrea es mínimo la incidencia que hay
entonces
lo que usted y Javier nos nos explica
Carlos haber hecho este vertido
controlado hacia estas fosas para
posteriormente hacer la quema controlada
fue el procedimiento adecuado no había
una forma de sacar esto de los
contenedores o de los vagones donde
estaban y pasarlos a otros tipos de
transporte y mantener protegido el
contenido químico lo mejor entonces en
este caso era claramente la quema
controlada y evitar hacer un traspaso
pese al volcamiento y pese a los
aparatoso como dice usted del accidente
como lo vio usted Carlos
en efecto si si hubiera tratado de hacer
un trasvase en material debido a las
circunstancias que estaba el
descarrilamiento se podía salir fuera de
control y hubiera ocurrido una explosión
y una explosión Estamos hablando Un
Rango de uno dos kilómetros a la redonda
que hubiera desaparecido todo lo que hay
alrededor Sí entonces hubiera
desaparecido la ciudad tenemos que
considerar una cosa muy importante no
hubo ninguna Muerte en ese
descarrilamiento sí en los casos que le
mencioné de que tuvimos aquí en la
Ciudad de México son más de dos mil dos
mil quinientas personas que fallecieron
claro es importante destacar eso un
procedimiento que preservó la vida de
los residentes de esta población Pero
entonces ahora Esto sí pasa una factura
Y es en términos medioambientales este
descarrilamiento y este vertimiento
Javier que impacto tiene entonces en el
medio ambiente se salvan las vidas
humanas se salva la población pero
lamentablemente el medio ambiente y la
contaminación de algunas aguas son las
[Música]
el impacto que pueda tener
sí adelante
el impacto ambiental digamos está Claro
en cuanto a los productos que se
desprenden de la incineración la nube
tiene que ver también con las
condiciones meteorológicas
de justamente por la tarde y por la
noche puede haber una una inversión
térmica y eso hace que el la dispersión
digamos de esos de esos humos se vea
retrasada Además del impacto ambiental
hay que ver también el impacto a la
comunidad no no olvidemos esto es una
comunidad de cinco mil habitantes fueron
evacuados la mitad del pueblo es un
montón esto casi dos mil cuatrocientas
personas y lo más importante digamos es
que el 20% de Ohio se nutre del turismo
industria que puede haberse afectada
Entonces siempre es importante también
la preparación algo que mencionas en
cuanto a los habitantes creo que no
tuvieron información hoy la tienen hoy
la agencia de protección ambiental y
recién ayer la empresa de trenes hizo
una publicación haciéndose cargo
absolutamente de las de las
consecuencias Pero la agencia de
protección Ambiental de Estados Unidos
desde el día cuatro tiene publicaciones
sobre mediciones ambientales que se han
hecho y de hecho por eso del seis
comienza la quema y el ocho se permite
el ingreso nuevamente a la ciudad dado
que se habían hecho las mediciones
correspondientes de que no había riesgo
a la salud para poder este ingresar Sí
fue muy importante la evacuación inicial
porque sí había riesgo a la salud y eso
se les informó a los a los habitantes
Pero bueno quizás muchas veces existe lo
que es la respuesta emergencia y el
personal está abocado esa respuesta y a
veces al no tener una buena
planificación el mismo personal de
respuesta es el que se tiene que
encargar de transmitir o de llevar
tranquilidad o certidumbre a la sociedad
y Eso debería estar a veces
me parece relacionado y que gente en el
mismo momento que se está brindando la
respuesta pueda hacer contención de la
población en este caso es muy importante
aparte por ejemplo de Según estaba
mirando unos estudios del censo del 2010
el 20% de la población también tiene
problemas de discapacidad Entonces eso
complejiza la evacuación y hace que
bueno que tengan que actuar diferentes
tipos de de agencias acá en este caso el
Gobierno Federal envió como les mencioné
antes a la junta nacional de
investigación de accidentes en el
transporte la agencia de protección
ambiental afirma que es la agencia de
manejo de emergencias que están en
carácter de asesores obviamente no se ha
declarado una emergencia Federal por las
características y dimensiones de evento
porque tiene que ser resuelto y fue
resuelto a nivel local hoy se está
haciendo la mediación del sitio No claro
quiero que entre ustedes dos nos
expliquen para los que no tenemos ni la
más mínima idea de químicos ni de todos
estos
[Música]
químicos que se utilizan para producción
de otro tipo de objetos que nos
expliquen De qué tipo de sustancias
estábamos hablando que estuvo expuesta
esta población ante este
descarrilamiento aquí se menciona
cloruro de vinilo cloruro de hidrógeno y
fosfeno esto Para qué se utiliza esto
como tiene implicaciones en el cuerpo si
hay contacto con ellos qué repercusiones
puede traer en la ciudadanía Si tiene
alguna exposición a ellos comienzo
entonces con Carlos veamos aquí la ronda
la inversa el club de vinilo te conoce
hace mucho tiempo Sí de hecho se
descubrió en 1835 como
situación así un poco esporádica después
en el cincuenta y 1850 se vuelve a
redescubrir se empieza a ver la
polimerización pero se vio de que podía
ser Útil para fabricar
plásticos a partir de
1929 es cuando se logra establecer una
forma de poder
estabilizarlo y poderlo plastificar de
hecho el polímero cloruro de polivinilo
que se obtiene a partir del monómero que
es el cloe vinilo es el tercer plástico
de mayor consumo a nivel mundial estamos
hablando de millones de toneladas que se
consumen a nivel mundial Para qué se
utiliza todas las tuberías de plástico
todas las tuberías de agua todas las
películas flexibles para la intemperie
son hechas aparte de de polivinilo la
ventaja del provee polivinilo es que es
un material que se puede formular desde
muy rígido hasta muy flexible y también
por ejemplo los guantes que utiliza uno
para protección son hechos a base de PVC
cloro de polivinilo claro Este es un
proceso de procedimiento un poquito
diferente entonces el vinilo lleva
muchos años usándose en forma muy masiva
millones toneladas y vacuna a partir de
los años mediados de los años setenta
como cuarenta y cinco años después de
que se descubrió y empezó a usarse se
vio que había una correlación entre las
gentes que trabajaban en las plantas que
fabricaban el PVC y utilizaban mucho el
monómero con cáncer de
hígado Entonces se hicieron más estudios
y se encontró una correlación de que una
exposición continua al monómero puede
producir cáncer de hígado cáncer de
pulmón cáncer cerebral etcétera Sí
también a leucemia pero Eh Esto es
posición a muy largo plazo exposición a
largo plazo es Javier complementemos
explicándole a la audiencia el cloruro
de hidrógeno y el fosfeno estamos aquí
un poco en clase de química pero es que
vale la pena entender a qué fue lo que
se estuvo expuesto esta población porque
esto puede ocurrir en cualquier otra
parte del mundo en cualquier momento
momento dado que es un químico usado
muchísimo en nuestra vida diaria de
acuerdo a lo que ustedes nos están
explicando
Sí a ver También es importante digamos
decir que podría haber residuos o que
por ejemplo el fugeno que mencionas era
una de las consecuencias de la quema
controlada
ahora gente cuesta fuje No tendríamos
gente muerta digamos no es un producto
altamente tóxico que haya sido
producto de la combustión y que se haya
calculado la disipación y justamente la
posibilidad de que en el ambiente
rápidamente se disperse eso fue parte
del trabajo además de las consecuencias
hay que entender algo digamos de los
valores que hoy tenemos y de la
exposición a cáncer son exposiciones
laborales sí de cinco días ocho días a
la semana Entonces perdón ocho horas a
la semana cinco días Eso quiere decir
que acá una exposición aguda que produjo
seguramente la irritación de vías
respiratorias y de eso y los olores que
haya olor no quiere decir que haya
exposición hay productos que tienen un
bajo u O sea que se sienten fuertemente
y sin embargo todavía no tienen este
presencia Y eso pasa mucho con los
productos que tienen alta toxicidad
igual es importante aclarar que este es
un gas Sí si bien está licuado es un gas
se transporta de manera líquida pero es
un cuando pasa rápidamente a fase
gaseosa y por eso también algo que
mencionabas no se podía hacer este
trasvase si el trasvase es fácil hacerlo
entre líquidos por un producto que está
este comprimido digamos justamente es es
muy difícil y por eso esa esa toma de
decisiones que que hubo No sí importante
es esa aclaración quiero preguntarles
por el manejo que ha tenido esto a nivel
de las autoridades ustedes hablan de un
buen manejo para esta emergencia a
través de la quema el vertimiento y todo
este tipo de Procedimientos pero que hay
de la transparencia que ha habido a lo
largo de los días con el manejo de la
información este caso puntualmente ha
sido uno de los más claros ejemplos de
desinformación y de falsas en redes
sociales y en diferentes medios de
comunicación sensacionalistas y para
señalar a las autoridades y criticar a
Estados Unidos y a las autoridades
federales que balance y qué análisis
pueden hacer ustedes esto se manejó
acorde a la situación se le dio la
importancia necesaria una respuesta
adecuada por parte del gobierno para dar
información a la comunidad a las
autoridades locales que análisis pueden
hacer comienzo con Javier para hacer la
ronda la inversa
perfecto gracias Sí me parece que
en este caso la población fue informada
porque se dio un orden de evacuación Y
eso hubo contacto directo con la con la
población pero después esto que
mencionas digamos de las digamos las
noticias falsas que lo que hacen es
aumentar la incertidumbre de la
población mucha gente no tiene las
herramientas para comprobar y tampoco
por ejemplo si uno entra a la página hoy
hoy de la agencia protección ambiental
puede ver las mediciones que se hicieron
hasta el día de hoy las ayer antes de
ayer las mediciones ambientales con
gente que tiene que perder digo los
funcionarios si mienten tienen para
perder y la empresa también hace otro
muestreo entonces Quizás por ejemplo la
página web de la empresa tiene poca
información remite a la agencia
protección ambiental y después la
gestión local no digamos pensemos que es
un pueblo de cinco mil habitantes un
pueblo chico donde las relaciones son
muy fraternas Entonces eso también puede
ayudar a rápidamente disipar estas
falsas noticias pero en un principio la
gente tiene desconfiar
hay una desconfianza de la población en
general muchas veces cuando suceden
estos eventos y creen que son este
burladas o que les mienten Pero la
realidad es que las autoridades son las
que tienen la mayor responsabilidad y
así lo asumen no me parece que que hoy
por hoy en el manejo de que hay de la
apertura de las redes sociales la
población no no puede ser vulnerada y se
le puede mentir y eso hoy las
autoridades este lo saben insisto con lo
anterior digamos que hubo recién el 15
de febrero una reunión con la con la
comunidad cuando el evento fue el tres y
se plantearon dudas o el y el titular de
la agencia de manejo de emergencia
estuvo en el lugar y también Atendió y
se obligó a la empresa a participar
porque en las primeras reuniones no
habían participado según ellos porque no
estaban garantizadas las condiciones de
pero es muy importante que los expertos
de las compañías que tienen eventos
participen de la atención a la población
y obviamente la atención del evento
porque son los que trabajan con el
producto son los que lo conocen y los
que están todos los días Entonces es muy
importante para llevar certidumbre es lo
que uno trata en una
población poder advertirlo Carlos su
opinión el manejo mediático de este caso
Sí una de las cosas más importantes que
hay que notar es que no hubo ni un
deceso en el caso sí Entonces desde mi
punto de vista ha sido manejado de forma
bastante acertada la situación podemos
recordar un accidente que hubo del ayuno
en la India en bopal en el cual murieron
en el día 2500 personas y durante un
período corto de tiempo hasta doce mil
personas murieron acá a causa de la
emanación de sociedad metilo que era un
intermediario para fabricar un
insecticida entonces ahí no se tomaban
las medidas adecuadas y fue una
hecatombe lo que hubo Sí aquí Se tomaron
las medidas adecuadas y no hay ningún
deceso hay efectos secundarios
obviamente Al haber mandado al medio
ambiente una gran cantidad de productos
va a tardar algo de tiempo en poder
limpiar eso Muchos de ellos el ácido
clorhídrico el fósfogeno se van a
neutralizar en el suelo Sí y los suelos
tienen una capacidad bastante fuerte de
neutralización como son gases también
hay una dispersión de ellos y no va a
haber tanto problema Entonces siento yo
que lo que
la problemática aquí es son situaciones
muy técnicas situaciones químicas que la
gente normal no le entiende totalmente y
está muy propensa a cualquier tipo de
filtración o cualquier tipo de
información falsa que se pueda dar Sí
justamente Carlos uno de los comentarios
que veía uno en las redes sociales era Y
ustedes lo mencionaban comparar este
descarrilamiento y esta y este
vertimiento de químicos al suelo con el
accidente de chernóbil en priat en
Ucrania bueno en la entonces Unión
soviética era comparable o esto
simplemente fue una oportunismo
periodístico de titulares alarmistas era
Comparado esto o no era de tal tamaño
porque lo de chernóbil estamos hablando
de una planta nuclear y aquí estamos
hablando de unos vagones de un tren
Carlos Ok correcto definitivamente no se
puede comparar para nada sí
vemos ahorita a pesar de que ha pasado
casi cuarenta años de chernóbil sigue
deshabitado no se puede utilizar ahí hay
lugares por ejemplo otro caso muy
dramático que hemos tenido de
contaminación es cuando los americanos
estaban peleando en Vietnam y se les
ocurrió utilizar lo que se llamaba el
Agente Naranja para desfoliar las las
selvas el Agente Naranja es desde el
punto de vista químico el ácido
triclorofenoxia sético cuando se produce
en cantidades muy grandes y no se tiene
control empieza a haber problemas de
formación de dioxinas también se
mencionó desde el principio que se
habían formado de oficinas
los productos químicos que se tenían en
el vagón no son precursores para
dioxinas la así puede permanecer
contaminando por mucho tiempo aquí era
principalmente bosque en lo que es gas
es muy venenoso pero se dispersa
fácilmente y ácido clorhídrico que
también si lo respira uno es muy
venenoso claro pero es el ácido que
utiliza uno para limpieza en su casa Sí
sí y Javier su su opinión este escándalo
a nivel mediático comparándolo con
chernóbil chernóbil como lo dice Carlos
pues está completamente desocupado
inhabitado es más un sitio casi que de
turismo
siniestro como lo llaman a esta
categoría del siniestro personas que van
a visitar esta zona que está abandonada
pero Hay riesgo todavía en el caso de
chernóbil Si la gente se acerca a esta
población Y a esta zona
bueno coincido con con Carlos no
plenamente Me parece que no no tiene
nada que ver y que esto es parte de lo
que hablábamos anteriormente que tiene
sensacionalistas o de mala información y
lo que hacen es esto alertar a la gente
entender que un problema
eligen nuclear justamente digamos donde
como menciona Carlos la ciudad después
de 30 años no ha sido nuevamente
habitada producto de la radiación que
hay no tiene nada que ver con un
accidente químico como este donde hoy se
está haciendo remoción donde se puede
hacer una remediación no remediación y
monitoreo es esta fase que está ahora de
trabajo donde se han sacado más de tres
mil metros cúbicos de tierra más de
cuatro mil metros Perdón
metros cúbicos de agua también o sea se
ha hecho se ha este haciendo un
tratamiento este para la su disposición
final y la posición de tierra sana
tratando de evitar justamente no vaya a
los recursos acuáticos subterráneos no
digamos pero teniendo en cuenta que este
producto si se derrama rápidamente pasa
fase gaseosa y Y eso digamos da cierta
tranquilidad en cuanto a la
contaminación que puede que puede llegar
a ver pero me parece este esto de
aclararlo digamos de lo de chernóbil no
tiene ninguna comparación tampoco a
Estados Unidos ha tenido desastres
químicos mucho más importantes locales
allá por el año setenta donde hicieron
una ciudad arriba un basurero químico
digamos ha tenido muchos eventos
muchísimo más grandes que este donde
esto es una resolución como les dije
anteriormente a nivel local con las
autoridades locales y con la asistencia
técnica de la empresa y de los del
Gobierno Federal claro yo Estados Unidos
tampoco estaba en la coyuntura política
en la que está ahora donde se buscan
este tipo de situaciones para hacer
señalamientos al gobierno de turno o
para señalar de un lado a otro
dependiendo de donde se mire llegamos al
final programa el bloque final hagamos
entonces las conclusiones de lo que nos
deja este tema importante haber aclarado
la parte técnica importante entender De
qué tipo de químicos estábamos hablando
y la magnitud de este de este accidente
y lo que puede repercutir en el tiempo
en materia medioambiental y para la
comunidad afectada comienzo entonces con
Carlos para la conclusión de lo que deja
este accidente de lo que deja lecciones
para que no se repita en el futuro y lo
que deja para la comunidad
en el caso de los accidentes químicos el
gobierno americano tiene un
organismo que se llama el isd que csv
que es química el cual hace una después
de que ocurre un accidente se hace una
investigación exhaustiva acerca de Por
qué ocurrió ese accidente para evitar
que vuelva a ocurrir un accidente
semejante la industria química a pesar
de que es una industria que maneja una
gran cantidad de productos muy
peligrosos es una de las Industrias que
menos incidentes tienen de laborales
esto es debido a que existe una
reglamentación muy estricta con respecto
a manejar los diferentes productos no es
inevitable manejar productos químicos
hay que usarlos a que sean peligrosos
pero hay que saber su peligrosidad y
saber cómo tomar medidas en el momento
que se tienen que resolver algún
percance y esto lo usamos también en la
Facultad de química de la UNAM donde
todos nuestros estudiantes estudian
hacen
utilizan los productos químicos y les
tenemos que dar una capacitación muy
estricta acerca de cómo manejarlo para
que no empiecen a manejarlo y vaya a
haber un accidente
y Javier su conclusión para el cierre
Bueno me parece importante destacar la
importancia de la preparación a
emergencias esto de que el gobierno haya
emitido un comunicado donde obligaba a
la empresa a participar de lo que se
denomina Comando incidente que es la
toma de decisiones donde están todos los
están haciendo la respuesta me parece
que habla que las empresas tienen que
justamente adelantarse a estos eventos
que son eventos que quizás no se pueden
prever uno no está preparado para
descarrilen 20 vagones y cinco se
prendan fuego Pero sí tiene que estar
preparado en conocer los productos
químicos en dar información en conocer a
las autoridades como les dije
anteriormente una emergencia es una
situación a resolver inesperada Y que
requiere muchas veces de inventiva y de
innovación pero teniendo la comunicación
el manejo de la información dando
tranquilidad y certidumbre a la
población de formación verás Me parece
que son herramientas para poder aprender
y para poder seguir desarrollando sobre
todo entender manipulación que tiene que
tener el sector privado con el estado
para lo que es la respuesta a emergencia
con productos químicos
pues este caso Apenas está empezando por
lo menos la emergencia ya fue controlada
ya fue manejada por las autoridades
ahora se viene toda una disputa a nivel
legal porque ya ha habido hasta el
momento cuatro demandas grupales
instauradas ante las autoridades contra
esta empresa dueña de este ferrocarril
que descarriló allí en el estado de Ohio
pues entonces ya el escenario a nivel
legal apenas y a nivel judicial apenas
va a empezar allá en Estados Unidos y
luego veremos pues la repercusiones que
esto tenga en materia medioambiental
pero por ahora la situación
Aparentemente Pues fue controlada por
las autoridades del estado de Ohio y
también con la ayuda de las autoridades
federales a Javier y a Carlos les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros seguramente volveremos a hablar
más adelante cuando este caso tenga
desarrollo periodístico que valga la
pena analizar aquí en el debate de
France 24 es todo por hoy En nombre del
equipo técnico Les agradecemos haber
estado con nosotros hoy en el programa
la producción de El Debate estuvo a
cargo de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera siga
con nosotros
[Música]